I just crossed my fingers on this one I
just I want to be good I want him to be
good Suicide Squad
so Suicide Squad is the newest movie in
the DC Cinematic Universe the most
different - it's directed by David Ayer
and ultimately Amanda Waller is a
government person played by Viola Davis
and she gets these wild ideas like all
right Superman
was a big deal and will't spoilers for
Batman vs Superman now Superman is just
kind of not around anymore so like what
if the next Superman is an [ __ ] so we
need to put together a team that might
be able to battle something bigger than
what we can take on so they compiled
this group of DC villains together
they're like all right now you are Task
Force X otherwise known as The Suicide
Squad now they got to go to solve a very
vague problem because I don't want to
give you spoilers and we have ourselves
a pretty [ __ ] office' movie I have
got to say you have a cornucopia of
characters that we haven't seen on
screen before they have no backstory
before this film so they got to do their
best with that premise but it is it's
worked before so why not have it work
now I feel like Suicide Squad hits that
point that DC needed to hit in their
film you wanted to have humor to make it
just more human and relatable because we
human beings we gravitate towards humor
but you don't want to have too much
humor to where it compromises the DC
Universe and they hit that perfectly
with Harley Quinn and Deadshot arlequin
is Fanta Margot Robbie as Harley Quinn
is every bit is brilliant as Harley
Quinn as you thought she would have been
when you heard she was cast as her she's
gorgeous sexy very kick-ass and very
nuts but also Will Smith as Deadshot he
brings loads of humanity to this movie
and also brings his Will Smith wit you
know that charisma that Will Smith has
is brilliant delivery on a comedic
moment that needed to happen because
right there you're like alright Will
Smith
say something perfect you said it and
you said it wonderfully and that's what
we needed for that moment
Will Smith can throw out comedy without
making the movie accommodate guess is
what I'm trying to say right there a lot
of kick-ass characters before I get into
the Joker I'm gonna let you know right
now can't believe I'm gonna say this I'm
gonna say something I never thought I
would say honest to god Jai Courtney was
good in this movie yeah I've never
really been the biggest Jai Courtney fan
I just feel like they're trying to shove
Jai Courtney down our throat but no he
was great he actually displayed a
likeability and a snore
to him that I didn't think Jai Courtney
had the ability to give us for Jared
Leto's Joker Jared Leto's Joker 8 thing
about the Joker first of all is that
he's such a malleable character he is a
psychotic chaotic [ __ ] however you
want to display or portray that I've
seen that portrayed so many ways in
comic books a few different ways in film
Jared Leto's Joker is another take on
the Joker's one that I have seen in
comic books not yet really on film he's
not Heath Ledger's Joker although his
voice is sometimes similar but his
mannerisms are completely different he
is that well dressed eccentric mob boss
think Scarface if Scarface did way too
much coke and they said nah I like meth
better that's that's this Joker but the
fact is if you're going into this
looking forward to seeing how the Joker
kicks so much ass he's not really in the
movie much he is a wild card in this
movie he's not by any means the point he
is a detached third party that has his
own agenda see we've grown so accustomed
to the Joker's dynamic with Batman and
how they bounce off of each other but
Batman's not really in this movie he
cameos in the beginning but for all in
all he's not really in it so what we get
is the Joker's dynamic with Harley Quinn
and how they work together and I really
like how they did lovely is enjoyer
madness I can't wait to see Jared Leto
get more screen time as the Joker I hope
in the standalone Batman movie we get
him as the main antagonist yes I know
we've seen the Joker be the main
antagonist a couple times before but
what can I say I want to see how this
guy brings it against Batman this movie
really won me over with the heart it
really has a lot of heart among the
characters it's great to see these
characters grow the scene where they're
all reflecting in the bar that you saw
in the trailer is one of my favorite
parts in the movie nothing's really
there's no excitement happening it's
just great character building I love
that it does have some pacing issues if
not balance issues periodically in this
film and I don't really blame this movie
for it it's like they're like we need to
give backstory to some of these
characters are pretty big power hitting
characters among the DC Universe you
can't just not give them backstories so
you have to give backstory and flashback
periodically throughout here and it
doesn't always gel there's not always a
smooth transition to do it but I would
rather they do it than not have it my
biggest gripe hands down and this entire
thing is there is a character who deals
with something in a certain way that I
just don't think you would deal with
I'll talk about it more on my Suicide
Squad spoiler talk but for right now
just all I can do is keep it vague and
I'm just saying this one scene this one
thing that happened maybe just look at
it more like
I don't think that dude would deal with
that like that and that really does
compromise his character for me a bit
but it's easily the most glaring issue
in the entire film really looking
forward to seeing more of what the DC
Cinematic Universe has to offer thus far
I hadn't really been blown away by
anything in that universe until now now
this is exactly what I needed I think
what we needed and I think what they
needed
soundtrack alone is worth it the set
track is great doesn't he had Suicide
Squad gave me what I was hoping it would
give me but gave me a lot more than I
actually thought it would give me he's
cleared by now that I loved this movie
but it is the best DC Cinematic Universe
movie that I have seen by a clear mile
most importantly this movie was a lot of
fun a lot of kick-ass rain a lot of
likeability a lot of banter with some
really cool characters and I will say
Suicide Squad is definitely worth
watching and definitely worth buying on
blu-ray right guys so Suicide Squad have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you